comedy duo tim and eric' generally drum
up controversy simply because their
comedy is so bizarre and it may not
always sit well with the typical
stand-up comedy fan but the work of Tim
Heidecker and Eric Wareheim has taken
some strange turns and their various TV
projects have made plenty of people
genuinely irate for many reasons here's
the untold truth of Tim and Eric think
of the children the fifth season of Tim
and Eric awesome show great job on Adult
Swim explored some pretty dark comedic
territory on at least one occasion Tim
and Eric got into some trouble for it a
sketch called
dream cream cast a young boy to attend a
dream sequence barbeque with Pierre a
reoccurring character who's really into
barbecued meat and meaning it dad
hi beautiful boy welcome to my dream
during a questionable seen the kid eats
hot dogs and turkey legs out of Pierre's
hands which made the kids parents very
uncomfortable the episode only aired
once before the parents complained
forcing the show to replace the kid with
an animated figure instead during their
first reddit AMA Tim and Eric said that
it was just easier to make the change
than to hurt anyone this means a spoil
there's a lot me taking advantage during
the run of awesome show
the most common allegation made by
viewers and critics was that the comedy
duo took advantage of the mentally ill
or intellectually disabled but whilst
much of the shows comedy relies on the
unusual personalities of amateur actors
only one of their stable of repeat
guests has ever said anything about not
being treated professionally alien
enthusiasts and puppeteer David liebe
Hart has occasionally accused Tim and
Eric of not paying him enough or not
taking him on their national tours and
those allegations were dropped pretty
quickly when Hart became a regular on
Tim and Eric's check it out with dr.
steve brule I'm afraid of puppets well
you don't have to be afraid of them just
by puppets are very well trained they
won't scare you no way Jose other
strange appearances have included the
rooms
Tommy Weiser and Robert Axelrod the
voice of Power Rangers Lord Zedd who are
this week's movies to watch saw dang
stranger I give you two kisses in three
wet mouths hi everyone
you have failed to complete the mission
schedule the unusual guest stars find
themselves in pretty good company but
the duo do omit to an unusual casting
process they told their 2012 audience at
the Sundance Film Festival we dig
through to the bottom of the pile of
headshots and find them then give them
lots of lines not everyone stuck around
to ask questions at Sundance though
Sundance fury it's not just parents that
have been upset with Tim and Eric
according to Entertainment Weekly at
least one third of the audience left the
2012 Sundance screening of Tim and
Eric's billion dollar movie many of the
remaining audience members were
apparently hostile accusing the
filmmakers of taking drugs or genuinely
trying to upset paying audiences Tim and
Eric fired right back however you've
trained a new material for Cutie's and
the film went on to earn a respectable
38 percent on Rotten Tomatoes
now that's a solid score for a movie
that was intentionally unwatchable tiny
hats weird as they are Tim and Eric have
garnered the attention of mainstream
comedy shows like Saturday Night Live
making Will Forte Will Ferrell and Fred
Armisen all cast members because of Tim
and Eric's unofficial association with
SNL it's not too surprising that in 2012
the long-running sketch show was accused
of stealing a popular awesome show
sketch concerning tiny hats while
Heidecker himself wasn't upset he called
the incident very interesting and said
that he looked forward to seeing the
repercussions on the Internet
go with the flow even if you don't
recognize Tim and Eric themselves they
do regularly work with a face you have
to recognize Flo from progressive
insurance before she started grinning
maniacally for progressive actress
Stephanie Courtney provided the
monstrous voice of joy Peters the
oppressive and cruel wife on the
original Adult Swim show Tom goes to the
mayor she would also appear as a music
video dancer in the same show a casting
director on awesome show and even
followed the joy when they made an
appearance on The Simpsons backup
singing about food blogs during Tim and
Eric's rap which they also wrote
[Music]
ah Eric dated a much younger woman
fans of 2010 era MTV may remember a two
season faux reality show called my life
is Liz starring high schooler Liz Lee as
she ventured off to college from
small-town Texas not long after the show
was dropped in 2013 22 year old Lee was
spotted just about everywhere with 37
year old Eric Wareheim then whilst the
relationship didn't seem to last long
both MTV hungry teens and Tim and Eric
devotees savagely criticized the
relationship for the huge age disparity
between the two Kim's secret life it's
not that Tim Heidecker is hiding any
deep dark secrets probably but he only
recently revealed that he has a wife and
child and it's a big surprise to his
legion of fans whilst vise made brief
mention of this back in 2013 the full
revelation came in the lyrics of his
most recent album in Glendale a serious
soft rock album about his life in
California previous high Decca albums
have been exclusively about bodily
excretions Herman Cain campaign songs or
parodies of basically everything else so
in glendale's honesty came as a shock
many fans still aren't sure about what
it all means
especially since Heidecker usually
maintains an Andy Kaufman like wall of
inauthenticity
about him Tim was stabbed the only other
time that Heidecker has been truly and
transparently honest about his actual
life was when he was almost killed in
2006 in both his now-defunct personal
blog and a later live storytelling
session Tim mapped out the deadly
assault the attack was made by a
neighbor's son who was evidently high on
PCP and included some pretty gory photos
of where he was knifed twice in the
shoulder I have to this day no memory of
the actual impact of the knife which is
kind of a fascinating thing to me that I
have known you know the adrenaline
running through my through my veins
as I'm being as I'm running up fountain
I think prevented any feeling of pain
after being stabbed and making a sprint
through the streets Heidecker ran into a
bar for assistance where the assailant
was tackled by a group of patrons the
real Tim Heidecker can never die because
he's a child who is this ever he's gonna
be alive is it just a just a crank the
mystery of dr. Brule hey I'm dr. Steve
Brule with some of the rules rules does
your milk taste sour antics of it check
the expiration date tell me one of the
duo's most popular characters is dr.
Steve Brule played by john c reilly the
good doctor is so popular even viewers
who despise tim and eric can appreciate
rules off-kilter exploration of mon life
tam
age of a bunch of other junk casters
access to pppp the end after many
appearances on awesome show dr. Brule
got a spinoff and was invited to do a
ton of old comedy interviews the only
problem is that Reilly outright refuses
to answer any questions about the
character instead representing himself
as an acquaintance of Brule in order to
maintain the goofy mystery about Steve
John that's clearly you not he was
wearing glasses Conan
now we'll probably never know the
influences that helped create the
character and Riley's refusal to
disclose a single idea makes him that
much stranger thanks for watching
subscribe to our YouTube channel to
watch more videos like the one you just
saw and leave us a comment to let us
know which is your favorite Tim and Eric
sketch
[Music]